une opération nettoyage de printemps
sous tension ce week end à saint émile
honoré en cause une décharge au coeur de
la forêt découverte le mois dernier par
l'association environnementale les
marcheurs cueilleurs qui la qualifie de
sauvages pour la municipalité il s'agit
d'un lieu de stockage temporaire
on voudrait juste que ce terrain soit
nettoyé que des analyses soient faites
pour savoir s'il ya bien s il ya bien
pollution du sol ou pas ou du sous sol
sachant qu'une rivière coule juste en
contrebas et depuis un mois on essaie de
voir avec la mer avec la mer en place
avec la mairie tout simplement pour
essayer de régler ce problème trouver
des solutions en commun nous lui tendons
la main on est prêt à lui apporter notre
aide et jusqu'à aujourd'hui à la refuse
ça n'est pas une déchetterie sauvage
j'insiste sur ce point c'est un terrain
communal privée fermée et interdite au
public un petit village rural n'a pas
les moyens dès qu'ils amassent un
matelas d'aller l'a mené jusqu'à la
déchetterie et donc il stocke les
déchets ramassés au quotidien sur ce
terrain fermé au public j'insiste est
régulièrement
voilà ces déchets sont rapatriés vers la
décharge et la maire de la commune de
s'interroger sur les motivations de
l'association fondée en septembre
dernier
nous sommes carrément des élections
municipales il ya beaucoup de vocations
qui naissent à un an des élections
municipales
reste que l'association estime avoir vu
des déchets présents depuis plusieurs
mois photo à l'appui voilà on voit que
là ça quand même je pense plusieurs mois
voire plusieurs années déjà
voilà par exemple qu'on voit ce tas de
produits toxiques il faut savoir qu'à
l'intérieur ces deux-là de la cie de la
peinture synthétique etc voilà quand on
s'approche et qu'on déterre un petit peu
parce que là on avait enlevé un petit
peu la terre risque est en dessous
l'accès à ce site n'a pas été possible
lors de l'opération de ce week end
l'association a déjà affirmé dans un
courrier adressé au maire et au préfet
utiliser toutes les voies légales pour
le faire disparaître